when you're sitting with your friends
you turn on the debate or whatever it is
you're watching and she says those lies
about Vladimir Putin that person goes
she's she's Hillary Clinton dude Hillary
Clinton's stupid yeah I think that memes
are ammunition in the Arsenal of
persuasion and they're not to be used on
every Target like the illiterate just
all yeah they work against certain
people that they'll be like hahaa yeah
but other times you've got to explain
her her role on the board of Boeing and
that she's part of War Machine and and
you're correct but everybody hates
Hillary Clinton she was one of the most
despised candidates we've ever seen
and that's one of the reasons she lost
in 2016 so when you show a picture of
Nikki Haley and call her Hillary the
people who don't know anything about it
instantly understand what that means I
would say though that we're living in
different times I I do think that
mimetic Warfare is certainly uh you know
influential uh but but the reality is is
that this isn't about oh well I like
Nikki Haley I'm going to vote for Nikki
Haley this is about one thing and one
thing only okay and that is getting
Donald Trump